et avec nous pour ce club if trèard
comme tous les lundis bonjour Yve merci
d'être là directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du Figaro et leséiste Mathieu
souquier bonjour Mathieu merci d'être
avec nous on va parler évidemment de la
crise agricole objectif des agriculteurs
faire le siège de Paris et d'autres
grandes villes du pays les blocages
seront nombreux aujourd'hui alors
comment le gouvernement peut-il répondre
à cette colère alors que les premières
mesures de Gabriel hatal n'ont pas
réussi à la calmer vous nous direz ce
que vous en pensez Alex on verra que la
toute la classe politique s'en par du
sujet oui on verra qu'on est loin d'un
consensus entre les différentes
formations politiques sur les solutions
à cette crise agricole et pour commencer
on va dans le berceau de la contestation
la région
[Musique]
Occitanie et on va donc en Occitanie à
Montpellier on retrouve Vincent Coste
bonjour Vincent merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Vincent
journaliste libre Vincent on disait
l'occitan a été le berceau he de cette
colère du monde agricole on en est où ce
matin tin est-ce qu'il y a encore des
points de blocage dans votre
région il y a encore des points de
blocage l'autoroute A9 n'est plus bloqué
entièrement comme elle a pu l'être de
façon un peu
exceptionnelle la semaine dernière
puisqu'elle était bloquée de la
frontière espagnole jusqu'à jusqu'à
orange mais il y a encore des pointes de
blocage anim et puis y a des des points
de blocage ponctuels hier soir par
exemple une plateforme de de Système U
sur la commune de de vendarg un barrage
filtrant éta installé sur cette
plateforme les les les les manifestants
ne laissant entrer que les ne laissant
plus entrer les les les denrées les
denrées étrangères les produits les
produits étrangères sur cette sur cette
plateforme mais c'est évidemment une
situation très évolutive et peut-être
qu'à l'instant où je vous parle il y a
des points de blocage qui sont levés
d'autres d'autres qui s'installent même
si aujourd'hui peut-être tout le monde a
le regard tourner vers ce qui se passe
du côté de Paris ouais et Vincent on le
disait l'occcitan ça a été le berceau he
de cette cette colère du du monde
agricole la contestation est profonde et
ancienne elle n'est pas
étente bien sûr alors historiquement
déjà hein le les grandes manifestations
de de de 1907 pour la crise pour la
crise viticole déjà les les les les
drames de Monredon dans les dans les
dans les années 60 également mais c'est
vrai que cette crise viticole cette
crise et ce mouvement des des
agriculteurs en ocitanie notamment dans
l'est de la région n'a n'a n'a pas
commencé la la semaine dernière en en
novembre dernier une grande
manifestation à Narbonne avait rassemblé
euh 4 5000 viticulteurs qui euh qui
dénonçaient euh un ralbol une euh des
revenus des revenus insuffisants euh et
qui demandaient des des solutions pour
pour aider leur leur filière en crise
euh de la même façon euh en début
d'année dernière le le 11 février on a
vu à à Montpellier une grande
manifestation de défense de la ruralité
de défense de la ruralité dans dans
toutes ces dimensions des terroirs des
territoires des traditions des des
cultures 13000 personnes à la la
surprise générale avaient participé à ce
rassemblement et que ce soit ce lors de
ce rassemblement de Montpellier que ce
soit lors de la manifestation des
viticulteurs de de Narbonne ou que ce
soit lors des des des diverses
manifestations et des barrage que l'on a
observé la semaine dernière ou que l'on
peut encore observer on se rend compte
que l'on retrouve souvent les les mêmes
les mêmes personnes la manifestation des
vignerons la la FNSEA et les jeunes
agriculteurs participai au côté des
vignerons il n y avait pas que des
vignerons de la même façon pour défendre
la ruralité il y avait des vignerons il
y avait des éleveurs il y avait il y
avait des la défense de tradition et de
de territoire de culture comme la
toromchie ou la course camargaise il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont qui sont
liées il y a une espèce de c'est vrai de
de colère sourde qu'on a senti monter
dans la R région euh ces derniers mois
par rapport par rapport à des décisions
des normes européennes ou nationales
jugé ou ou des pratiques ou des coutumes
ou des ou des injonctions ou des ou des
positions peut-être des fois jugées
moralisantes jugé trop contraignante
trop voire trop coeritive quelque chose
était en train de se passer et
finalement ce ce mouvement des des
agriculteurs d'aujourd'hui n'étonne pas
tant que ça dans nos dans nos
territoires dans notre région merci
Vincent merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous on suivra bien sûr ce mouvement
avec vous dans votre région regarde la
une du midiip c'est un autre sujet dans
les rau la route tue toujours plus c'est
à la Une de votre journal aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup Vincent Coste d'avoir été
avec nous un mot hi parce que Vincent le
rappel c'est c'est pas nos dents si
cette colère et ce mouvement il est
parti du Sud-Ouest et et de cette région
Occitanie oui parce que c'est une région
qui est traditionnellement très agricole
viticol même c'est c'est c'est évident
mais j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'intérêt
ce que venait de dire mon confrère parce
que en fait on parle souvent d'un choc
de civilisation quand on parle d'autre
chose mais là on est un peu dans un choc
de civilisation au sens où on est en
train dans un dans un point de
transition de basculement même où et
bien il y a des traditions il y a des
coutumes il y a des je dirais des des
des cultures qui sont remises en
question à cause justement de cette euh
bah du réchauffement climatique de
l'adaptation
de de certaines processus de production
à une modernité qui est exigée
aujourd'hui
et je comprends que ça c'est c'est c'est
c'est le gros défi qu'on a à relever
comment faire pour que tous ces métiers
qui sont des métiers absolument
nécessaires et des
métiers qui sont je dirais qui nous qui
nous nourrissent qui sont vraiment
essentiel à notre à notre civilisation à
notre vie puisse perdurer puisse
continuer à vivre normalement à gagner
leur vie tout en
s'adaptant aux exigences je dirais de du
respect de
l'environnement c'est c'est c'est c'est
un défi qui est immense et personne n'a
trouvé la solution Mathieu on est
au-delà de de de simples revendications
d'agriculteur hier Gabriel Atal disait
l'agriculture c'est une part importante
de l'identité de la France on est aussi
là-dedans oui alors juste un mot chez
nous ça part d'Occitanie c'est vrai
enfin rappelons que on se situe dans un
mouvement qui est en fait européen il y
a déjà eu précisément des mouvements
chez les agriculteurs en Allemagne en
Roumanie ailleurs donc ce qui se passe
en France pour le coup n'a rien de
spécifiquement français en revanche là
où vous avez raison c'est que il y a
chez nous une place symbolique de
l'agriculture et du monde paysan qui
n'existe pas ailleurs parce que la
République précisément elle s'est fondé
sur deux piliers un le monde paysan deux
les fonctionnaires les Anglais c'est les
ouvriers et les commerçants donc on voit
bien que chaque histoire précisément où
chaque identité nationale se réfère à
des choses différentes et puis rappelons
que en France la la population rurale
est restée majoritaire jusque dans les
années 50 pareil en Angleterre c'était
un siècle plus tôt donc la ruralité chez
nous a une place très grande ce qui me
frappe par ailleurs quand même c'est de
voir que ce monde agricole alors pour
les raisons que que y évoquait en fait
se sent totalement abandonné alors que
précisément il est chez nous
symboliquement très aimé et d'une
certaine façon on en reparlera mais le
fait que toute la classe politique se
porte à son chevet et dise pas toujours
la même chose mais en tout cas disent
tout le monde dit à l'unisson de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon jusqu'à Marine Le Pen
nous devons écouter les agriculteurs et
nous devons précisément répondre à à
leurs attentes un monde symboliquement
très aimé très considéré et quand même
objectivement matériellement
financièrement très aidé donc il y a un
petit décalage enfin il y a un petit
décalage en tout cas on peut observer
quand même une forme de décalage entre
le mal-être paysan et la façon dont la
communauté nationale se situe
symboliquement et matériellement
derrière eux et y compris l'Europe
puisqueencore une fois les subventions
viennent beaucoup beaucoup de Bruxelles
essentiellement de Bruxelles bien sûr
oua on va revenir à la question des
blocages puisque après despuses ce
weekend les blocages repartte
aujourd'hui et notamment l'objectif
annoncé par la FNSA c'est de faire le
siège de Paris mais Gérald haranin
prévient il y aura pas de tracteur dans
les grandes villes on voit ça avec Flor
sauvage des blindés de la gendarmerie
déployé aux abords de ringiste les
agriculteurs en colère sont décidés ce
lundi à bloquer la capitale la FNSEA et
les Jeunes Agriculteurs du bassin
parisien ont prévu SEP points de blocage
autour de Paris à partir de 14h malgré
les annonces du gouvernement les
annonces qui ont été faites pour nous
elles sont insuffisantes il y a plein de
sujets qui n'ont pas été abordés dans
les sujets qui ont été abordés il y a
encore des choses qui restent très
floues on a plutôt l'impression bah que
c'est un pansement sur une jambe de bois
à l'issue d'une réunion
interministérielle de crise dimanche le
ministre de l'Intérieur Géral de
Darmanin a annoncé la mobilisation de
15000 forces de l'ordre tout en assumant
de laisser faire les agriculteurs les
forces de l'ordre les sers et les
gendarmes mobile n'ont pas comme
consigne d'intervenir sur les points de
blocage mais d'accompagner ces points de
blocage pour laisser sécurisé pour
éviter les drames qu'on a pu connaître
au début du du mouvement lorsqu'ils
étaient un petit peu si je veux dire
sauvag et sans organisation de
sécurisation 3 jours après les annonces
du gouvernement la colère des
agriculteurs ne faiblit pas le président
de la FNSEA a exhorté dimanche le
Premier ministre à aller beaucoup plus
loin pour satisfaire les demandes de la
profession on sent qu'il y a de la
prudence math souer de la part de Géral
Lain qui d'un côté dit pas de blocage
pas de tracteur dans les grandes villes
et on va surveiller tout ça mais d'un
autre dit donne des consignes de
modération on n'intervient pas sur les
points de blocage on les sécurise oui
alors effectivement parce que c'est une
profession qui a un pouvoir de nuisance
réel alors je dirais c'est pas nouveau
il y a toujours eu une forme de
mensuétude vis-à-vis des grands
mouvements agricoles encore une fois les
révoltes agricoles elles sont
récurrentes elles sont en réalité
souvent assez violentes he il y a
précisément en fait dans cette culture
paysane là une revendication qui peut
virer à une forme de déruptivité et de
débordement sociaux donc c'est pas
nouveau la mensuétude n'est pas nouvelle
ce qui est nouveau quand même c'est d'en
faire état publiquement surtout quand
précisément on appartient à un
gouvernement qui fait du retour à la du
retour de l'autorité au qui surjoue en
matière de retour à l'autorité une
dimension forte de de son de son
discours politique donc quand Géral
Darmanin l'autre soir dit effectivement
je les laisserai faire je les laisserai
faire dans un contexte où la demande
d'ordre est assez forte c'est assez
saisissant et en même temps ça dit bien
que précisément il y a un soutien
populaire très fort derrière ce
mouvement et on peut même dire quelque
chose d'assez nouveau on a vu qu'il y
avait des
successive qui s'était exprimé dans le
pays on a eu la colère de la France
purbaine avec la France des gilets
jaunes on a eu la colère du monde du
travail et des syndicat avec la réforme
des retraites on a eu la colère du monde
des banlieux l'été dernier et là c'est
précisément une 4è colère qui correspond
à une 4e France la France rurale ce qui
est frappant c'est de voir
l'enchaînement de ces colères et
l'enchaînement aussi rapproché de ces
colères on a déjà eu des grands
mouvements de contestation ma 68 on a eu
des réformes des retraites contesté on a
déjà eu des révoltes agricoles mais
précisément en fait l'emboîement de ces
grandes révoltes encore une fois
remontant à quatre Frances différentes
avec à chaque fois un soutien populaire
très fort y compris quand il y a des
violence alors dès les gilets jaunes on
l'avait vu en fait le mouvement était
avait suscité une sympathie constante
alors même que pour les tris/4s des
Français alors même que les les
débordements étaient visibles
quotidiennement sur nos écrans de
télévision mais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que ça dit parce qu'Emmanuel Macron en
2017 il avait fait campagne sur le fait
qu'il voulait réduire la fracture
territoriale aujourd'hui vous parlez de
ces qu de France ça veut dire qu'elle
est plus présente que jamais cette
fractureors ça veut dire qu'il y a
incontestablement une intensification
des colères qu'il y a incontestablement
une accélération des temps sociaux
encore une fois autant de révoltes en
aussi peu de temps c'est frappant
peut-être il y a-t-il al c'est juste une
hypothèse et pas du tout un procès
d'intention peut-être il y a-t-il aussi
dans le style de gouvernance macronienne
quelque chose qui suscite encore plus
que d'habitude la colère dans l'opinion
peut-être une forme de d'arrogance
technocratique ou de parisianisme du
pouvoir qui peut précisément dans
certains territoires susciter une forme
de de réaction pour partie épidermique
et pour parti pour partie irrationnelle
car encore une fois je le dis le monde
paysan est un monde est un monde qui est
symboliquement très aimé qui est
matériellement très soutenu et donc je
rappelle que le président Macron
lui-même a a veillé à être son chevet en
fait dès le départ on se souvient que
Julien de Normandie était un ministre de
l'Agriculture extrêmement populaire
auprès des milieux agricoles parce que
précisément sans aller jusqu'à parler
d'une forme de clientélisme en tout cas
il y avait une oreill très attentive
porté à leur revendication et on se
souvient même que Nicolas HULLOT avait
démissionné du gouvernement en en
observant que il était lui-même en fait
totalement dépossédé face aux lobis
agricoles donc voilà il y a il y a
toujours une forme d'ambivalence
derrière tout cela il y a de
l'ambivalence oui il y a une forme
d'ambivalence enfin bon il y a une
réalité aussi hein la réalité c'est que
vous avez de deux fois moins
d'agriculteur aujourd'hui que il y a 30
ans la réalité c'est qu'il y en a un qui
se qui qui se donne la mort tous les de
jours la réalité c'est que vous avez une
politique agricole commune qui a
complètement été modifiée si vous voulez
je le rappelle régulièrement mais il y a
il y a 40 ans 75 % du budget européen
allait à l'agriculture et sur ces 75 %
la moitié allit à la France hein c'était
un choix qui avait été fait l'Allemagne
industrielle et la France La France
Agricole tout ça a changé aujourd'hui
l'agriculture c'est 30 % du budget
européen aujourd'hui euh un budget
beaucoup plus important qu'il y a 40 ans
oui mais euh néanmoins la part du gâteau
est beaucoup moins importante pour la
France et d'e part et puis
deuxièmement vous avez quand même la
politique qui a été conduite et c'est ça
ils sont on n parle pas assez mais il y
a quand même des des causes
circonstancielles le Green Deal de
Madame Van derleen ils sont à fond
contre est-ce que vous avez lu ce que
c'est que ce pacte vert le pacte vert de
Madame Van derleyen c'est la cause de
tout ça de tout de enfin une partie une
grande partie de la de la colère des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui qui ne veulent
pas et bien accepter ce pacte vert qui
qui c'est vrai très excessif est un peu
hors sol parce que il il met des
barrières il met surtout des des je
dirais des des objectifs qui qui
paraissent inatteignbles en si peu de
temps en rappelant y précisément comme
le rappelit Pascal canenfin il y a
quelques jours que à ce stade ce pacte
vert précisément ne s'applique pas en
fait il constitue une perspective oui
oui mais d'accord mais c'est une
perspective qui le qui leur fait
extrêmement peur porté justement par un
homme qui s'appelle Pascal campfin qui
lui est aussi horors sol complètement
pourquoi mais par que parcecfin c'est un
député Renaissance député europé riste
surtout il est d'abord député sur la
liste Renaissance d'abordputé non non
mais il est d'abord député écologiste
c'estàd qu'il a fixé des bornes il a
fixé des objectifs qu'on ne peut pas
remplir c'est un mensonge c'est une
hypocrisie de penser que les
agriculteurs peuvent en si peu de temps
s'adapter de la sorte c'est une
hypocrisie alors moi je veux bien qu'on
soit dans l'idéologie totale mais cette
idéologie parce que c'est une idéologie
qui est alors que ça demanderait
beaucoup de pragmatisme il y a pas de
pragmatisme et ces objectifs qui sont
fixés ce sont des objectifs que les
agriculteurs ne peuvent pas tenir mais
pardon le Green Deal n'est juste pas un
fantasme en fait sorti de l'esprit d'un
écologiste forcené qui serait Pascal
qu'enfin le Green Deal précisément a été
mis sur la table par l'Europe la
Commission européenne est adoptée par le
G sont qui pardon tous ces gens c'est
qui mais le Parlement européen a adopté
je dire évidemment mais est-ce qu'ils
sont hors sol ou pas je sais pas si on
pe je sais pas si on peut considérer que
la représentation europé grandement hor
sol
regardez on diserte on diserte sur
l'évolution du monde et tout ça mais là
il y a des causes directes des causes
directes à la à la manifestation aux
colères d'aujourd'hui et ces causes
directes elles ont racine elles prennent
racine dans des décisions politiques il
faut quand même faut qu'on arrête de
disserter dans dans l'absolu ell
prennent racine dans des décisions
politiques qui sont souvent des
décisions politiques qui sont
irréalistesou je dirais juste deux
choses là-dessus alors un encore une
fois ce Green Deal quand même fait
l'objet d'un accord entre des pays et
des partis politiques est-ce que c'est
pas pour ça qu'il faut pas le contester
non mais d'accord mais je sais pas si
dans quelle mesure on peut dire que
c'est horol en tout cas ça n'est pas
vous l'avez dit vousmême toute l'Europe
est en agricole est en est en colère oui
mais je l'ai dit aussi encore une fois
ce Green Deal aujourd'hui ne s'applique
pas pour en revanche aller dans le sens
pour aller en revanche dans le sens de
ce que dit Yve il serait tout à fait
fâcheux que à l'on d'une crise comme
celle-ci on en reviennent à une
opposition frontale entre l'agriculture
et l'écologie puisque on sait que la
transition environnementale oui mais on
sait mais précisément donc il faut
dépasser ça puisque on sait que la
transition environnementale sera
nécessairement une transition
alimentaire et juste deuxième point
pardon en réalité ce qu'on observe c'est
que enfin il me semble que ce qu'on
observe là avec le monde agricole dit
quelque chose de plus global en réalité
et fait écho à d'autres choses qu'on
observe pendant très longtemps en France
en tout cas nous nous étions obsédés par
une réalité sociale qui écrasait toutes
les autres le chômage de masse on voit
bien que précisément avec la baisse du
chômage on s'est déporté vers une autre
préoccupation qui est très générale le
fait pour de très nombreuses catégories
d'actif de très nombreuses catégories
d'actifs dans notre pays le fait de
travailler sans pouvoir vivre dignement
de son travail ça vaut de façon
extrêmement net pour les agriculteurs
mais on voit que de nombreuses autres
professions de nombreux autres métiers
en réalité sont frappés et que la
revendication qui monte aujourd'hui dans
le pays et pas que chez nous d'ailleurs
mais très fortement dans le pays c'est
de pouvoir travailler et de vivre
dignement de son travail oui d'accord
mais je veux bien mais à partir du
moment où c'est acceptable et ça peut
être accepté or ce que ce que l'on voit
mais il suffit d'aller dans les campagne
vous y allez non vous allez voir dans
les fermes enfin moi ça m'arrive assez
régulièrement vous voyez les conditions
de travail qui sont avec des objectifs
avec des je dirais des des des
obligations qui sont des obligations
mais mais hors sol hors sol allez voir
allez voir un un éleveur moi je parle
pas des céréaliers par exemple parce que
on met tout ça dans le même sac aussi
les séréaliers très bien les séréaliers
ils se sont adaptés ils ont les moyens
parce que ils ont des très grandes
surfaces ça c'est un c'est un c'est un
sujet qui qu'il faudrait aussi qu'il
faudrait aussi évoquer mais vous prenez
les les les les producteurs de fruits et
légumes vous prenez les éleveurs et les
éleveurs dans certaines catégories les
éleveurs notamment mais c'est des
particularités avec des obligations ils
sont soumis à des obligations terribles
et en plus et en plus il faut le dire et
Stéphane Lefol l'a pas dit assez l'a pas
dit suffisamment fort là il y a quand
même un problème de négociation avec la
grande distribution quand est-ce qu'on
va quand même mettre ça sur le tapis et
juste pour repréciser sur cette question
des normes environnementale européenne
alors certes il y a le pacte vert qui a
été bien lancé à partir de 2019 avec
la fameuse loi de la ferme à la
fourchette et des nouvelles obligations
pour les agriculteurs mais on peut
rappeler aussi que depuis 1 an il y a un
mouvement de freinage des normes
écologiques en Europe notamment avec une
alliance entre la droite européenne et
des les groupes d'extrême droite au
Parlement europérain par exemple la loi
sur la biodiversité sur la restauration
de la nature elle a été vidée de sa
substance au Parlement européen il y
avait aussi une loi pour réduire d'ici à
2030 l'utilisation des pesticides elle a
été rejetée par le Parlement européen et
puis on peut quand même rappeler que la
Commission européenne et bien a donné
son autorisation au glyphosate pour 10
nouvelles années que la France s'est
abstenue ce qui a permis aussi et bien
la prolongation du glyphosate donc il y
a pas non plus et bien un mouvement très
dur de transition écologique en Europe
pour l'agriculture en ce moment oui mais
enfin néanmoins la menace est là et je
peux vous dire que les agriculteurs ils
la vivent cette menace he parce qu'il
savent ils savent jamais est-ce que vous
savez les investissements qui sont
obligés de faire les agriculteurs les
investissements qui sont obligés de
faire qui sont des investissements qui
leur sont sont dictés souvent par
justement ceux qui leur qui leur
fournissent la les graines qui leur
fournissent les les enfin tout tout les
produits dont ils ont besoin pour
exercer leur métier mais c'est dém
c'està dire qu'il faut arbitrer entre
agriculturecolog mais rendez-vous compte
vousbit entre agriculture et écologie
est-ce qu'on demande trop d'écologie au
détri de notre agriculture sujet est là
on raisonne en citadin mais allez dans
les campagne allez avec votre fermier à
à la banque vous savoir vous allez voir
si la banque elle lui fait crédit mais
évidemment que non pourquoi parce qu'il
y a un avenir qui est beaucoup trop
incertain comment vous expliquez
qu'aujourd'hui il y a 500000 exploit il
y a même pas il y a 350000 exploitations
en France là où il y en avait 1 million
il y a 40 ans il a quand même un
problème non grand parties qui vont
partir à la retraite dans les 10 années
à venir mou il y a un mouvement de
remembrement aussi on a fait des plus
grandes alors on est 67 millions
d'habitants alors que il y a 40 ans nous
étions 55 donc il y a il y a et puis
encore une fois il faut faire très
attention parce que c'est vrai que
l'agriculture et Stéphane Lefol a eu
raison de le souigner l'agriculture est
excédentaire si on regarde la balance
commerciale on exporte plus grâce au vin
et au spiritueux voilà mais il y a
beaucoup de filières qui sont
déficitaires
on exporte on importe beaucoup je
rebondis sur ce que dit ça dit
effectivement quelque chose de
l'acceptabilité d'une mutation à opérer
alors encore une fois la concentration
que vous évoquez c'està-dire la division
par TR ou quatre du nombre
d'exploitations en 30 ou 40 ans c'est un
mouvement de concentration ça ne veut
pas dire encore une fois que tous les
agriculteurs ou tous les exploitants
agricoles aujourd'hui meurent de faim ça
veut juste précisément dire que on a une
agriculture qui s'est concentrée pour se
moderniser mais derrière la
concentration il y a effectivement la
question de la mutation et encore une
fois comme la transition
environnementale sera aussi une
transition alimentaire pas uniquement
une transition énergétique mais une
transition alimentaire la question est
de savoir quelle est l'acceptabilité
d'une d'une telle mutation et puisqu'il
n'est pas question de ne pas faire cette
mutation puisqu'il n'est pas question de
ne pas faire cette transition de la
rendre acceptable en conditionnant en en
en formatant en adaptant notre soutien
et précisément en en accompagnant
différemment les professions qui sont
les plus touché mais sûrement pas en
riant nos ambitions à la matière alors
on a vu hier Gabriel hatthal et Marine
Le Pen sur le terrain Gabriel hatthal
qui doit faire de nouvelles annonces
discours de politique générale demain
mais Alex c'est la classe politique dans
son entièreté qui est mobilisée pour
aider les agriculteur oui a commencé par
le ministre de l'Agriculture Marc fen
qui doit faire le service aprèsvendre
des annonces du Premier ministre qui ont
été faites vendredi les premières
annonces puisque Marc fenau a indiqué
hier qu'il y aura des annonces
supplémentaires cette semaine pour nos
agriculteurs on l'écoute il y aura des
mesures complémentaires soit de niveau
européen soit de niveau national qui
continueront à être égrainé au long de
la semaine par qu'on a besoin d' TR oui
d mardi sans doute des choses
complémentaires on a besoin d'avoir des
mesures qui viennent crédibiliser la
parole publique crédibiliser la parole
européenne sur un certain nombre de
sujets alors du côté de l' opposition
c'est un peu facile mais on pointe la
responsabilité des différents
gouvernements d'Emmanuel Macron qui ont
été au pouvoir depuis 7 ans et notamment
au rassemblement national on estime que
leur politique aurait même détruit nos
campagnes écoutez Sébastien chunu la
philosophie d'Emmanuel Macron celle de
Gabriel c'est une philosophie qui amène
à effacer notre ruralité comme ils ont
d'ailleurs effacé les petits commerçants
les petits artisans parce que ça ne
correspond pas à leur modèle leur modèle
de société ne se satisfait pas de G qui
sont indépendants enracinés et qui
représentent finalement une part de
notre histoire économique et sociale le
rassemblement national qui demande
également la fin des accords de libre
échange qui feraient du mal à notre
agriculture française c'est ce que
demandent aussi les républicains le
patron du parti LR Eric sootti interrogé
dans le Journal du Dimanche propose
aussi une intervention de l'État pour
garantir un revenu minimum de 1500 € à
chaque agriculteur je le cite nous
devons mettre en place un dispositif
d'accompagnement financier des
agriculteurs qui vivent sous le seuil de
de pauvreté aucun agriculteur ne doit
gagner moins de 1500 € net par mois et
ce revenu minimum il serait financé par
des amendes que pont les industriels qui
ne respectent pas la loi égalim pour
garantir des prix décents à nos
agriculteurs et puis du côté de la
gauche et bien les écologistes récusent
les critiques qui sont portées
actuellement contre les normes
environnementales et contre l'écologie
qui est tout frais à la vie de nos
agriculteurs écoutez Yannick jado dans
notre pays depuis depuis 20 ans on a
quasiment pas réduit le niveau de
pesticide que ce gouvernement passe son
temps à taper sur les écologistes mais à
annuler toutes les mesures écologiques
c'est pas l'écologiste qui est
responsable de la crise agricole depuis
30 ans c'est quand même gonflé donc
voilàiana il y a pas du tout d'unité
politique sur cette crise agricole non
on le voit et du coup est-ce que ça va
être compliqué pour Gabriel hatal qui
est attendu demain une nouvelle fois sur
le sujet est-ce que jusqu'à maintenant
il a bien géré cette crise agricole
oui moi personnellement je trouve qu'il
est assez courageux quand même je ne dis
pas que on peut régler cette crise du
jour au lendemain c'est une crise qui
est profonde qui vient de loin qui est
compliquée à résoudre mais je trouve que
déjà le discours qu'il a fait enfin les
discours les propositions qu'il a fait
vendredi même si c'est il a fait
beaucoup de politique c'est normal il
est assez courageux et
euh maîtrise quand même assez bien son
son dossier pour quelqu'un qui qui vient
d'arriver comme ça quand vous voyez qui
pose ses feuillets sur botte de foin
puis qui commence à parler sans notes si
vous voulez vous dites que il est pas là
c'est pas un touriste quoi hein euh donc
non et mais bon il va falloir
effectivement qu'il y ait des
négociations alors après c'est la foire
si vous voulez à la démagogie quoi quand
pardon mais quand j'entends monsieur
Coti euh les républicains qui veut faire
un revenu minimum des agriculteurs je
suis sûr que les agriculteursivers
agricole il voudrait surtout pas en
avoir un je les agriculteurs sans doute
euh donc donc non il faut il faut être
sérieux quoi ce qu'il faut voir à mon
avis il y a il y a plusieurs il y a deux
directions dans lesquelles travailler il
y a effectivement l'adaptation et
l'adaptabilité des normes écologiques
qu'il faut travailler non pas qu'il faut
les supprimer mais il faut voir en quel
de quelle façon elles sont je
dirais on peut les introduire dans le
processus de fabrication et de
production et puis deuxièmement les
relations entre producteurs et la
distribution qui me paraissent là
absolument essentielle bonne gestion de
prise Mathieu euh alors on va voir
l'issue ce qui est sûr c'est que
évidemment il y a une surenchère
politique bon je sais pas si elle est
navrante en tout cas elle est
compréhensible à quelques mois de de des
élections européennes en tout cas on
voit bien que le contexte fait que la
surenchère politique paraît presque
naturel la question est celle de la
surenchère en fait au niveau de la FNSA
parce que rappelons que c'est un
mouvement qui a émergé de façon
relativement spontanée on a cru qu'on
allait avoir des bonnets jaunes comme on
avait eu des gilets jaunes c'estàdire en
fait voilà hors des cadres institués des
cadres institutionn habituels donc il y
avait précisément des révoltes à droite
et à gauche qui n'étaient pas le fait de
la FNSEA et puis là on a vu qu' au
contraire la FNSEA notamment en fait
voulait reprendre la main sur le
mouvement et là où ces mouvements
spontanés avaient commencé à se calmer
et où d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
leaders avaient dit bah les premières
réponses de Gabriel Atal en fait nous
suffiseent ell correspondent précisément
à ce qui était le fond de notre
revendication donc on plie les Gaules et
puis on on arrête on rentre à la maison
on rentre à la ferme là on voit que au
contraire c'est la FNSEA qui accélère
sur le champignon et donc la question va
être celle du rapport de force et donc
de l'autorité dont précisément Gabriel
Atal va va va pouvoir faire preuve dans
le contexte sachant que il est vrai que
depuis 2017 en fait le macronisme aux
affaires en fait ne se distingue pas par
sa capacité de dialogue social et par la
considération qui est en général marquée
vis-à-vis des corps intermédiaires alors
et Gabriel peu changer ça on l'a vu
vendredi soir est au milieu dans les
barrages d'agriculteurs en Occitanie
pour aller dialoguer directement avec
les agriculteurs est-ce qu'il peut
changer cette méthode il est
incontestable que si on dit souvent que
Gabriel Atal ressemble très fortement à
Emmanuel Macron à son maître on voit que
dans la gestion de crise aussi
précisément il a une capacité de
réactivité qui à chaque fois s'illustre
sur le harcèlement scolaire quand il
était ministre de l'éducation nationale
sur la BA on voit bien que c'est
quelqu'un qui a un sens politique et une
réactivité politique qui précisément ne
peut que le servir est-ce que ça suffira
ça précisément on verra et on suivra ça
notamment cette semaine la crise
agricole qui fait toujours la Une de
plusieurs de vos cotidiens régionaux on
voit ça avec
Alex
et Alex les agriculteurs veulent bloquer
les grandes villes et oui objectif pour
les agriculteur faire le siège de Paris
c'est à la Une du journal L'Union
aujourd'hui ou encore prendre en tenail
la ville de Lyon c'est à la Une du
journal Le Progrès plusieurs points de
blocage vont être organisés autour des
différentes agglomérations du territoire
le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald de
Darmanin jusque-là accusé de laxisme
face aux agriculteurs a promis quand
même un dispositif important pour
empêcher les tracteurs de rentrer entré
dans la capitale et et dans les grandes
villes 15000 agents des forces de
l'ordre vont être mobilisés des blocages
qui continuent malgré les annonces du
Premier ministre Gabriel Atal vendredi
destiné à calmer les agriculteurs et
d'ailleurs cette semaine c'est l'heure
de vérité pour Gabriel Atal et oui
l'heure de vérité c'est le titre à la
Une de La Dépêche du Midi puisque demain
Gabriel Atal prononcera son discours de
politique générale un discours percuté
par la crise agricole et par eux une
ministre de l'éducation et des Sports
Amélie a Castera très affaiblie par les
polémiques le plus jeune premier
ministre de la 5e République devra
réussir ce grand oral pour rassembler
une majorité présidentielle divisée ces
derniers mois assoir également son
autorité auprès de ministres ambitieux
qui l'entoure et puis montrer qu'il peut
apporter des solutions rapides au
problèmes du pays puisqu'il a fait de
l'efficacité sa ligne de conduite des
nouvelles un peu plus positives sur le
marché du logement et oui c'est à la une
de la voie du Nord dans les région dans
la région haut-fance et bien les acteurs
du marché de l'immobilier entrevoi une
légère embellie pour 2024 dans cette
crise du logement puisque les taux de
prês immobilier devrait baisser cette
année sur le marché les prix de biens
sont à la baisse sauf sans dans
certaines zones touristiques très tendu
donc l'offre est plutôt accessible aux
acheteurs fini l'euphorie des prix et
puis cette dynamique devrait être
accompagnée par des mesures de l'État
pour favoriser la production de logement
neufs autant de signaux qui apportent et
bien un certain optimisme au secteur on
finit par du sport et la belle victoire
de ne ballur et oui l'équipe de France
de hball a été sacré championne d'Europe
hier en battant le Danemark 33 à 31
c'était à Cologne c'est à la Une
aujourd'hui du journal L'Alsace une
victoire qui a été arrachée dans les
prolongations dans les derniers instants
du match c'est le 4e titre européen de
leur histoire il l'attendaiit depuis une
décennie depuis 2014 et ce titre et bien
il s'ajoute aux six titres mondiaux de
l'équipe de France et à ces trois titres
olympiques alors maintenant on ne va pas
leur mettre l'IM la pression mais
l'échéance la plus important l'échéance
la plus importante c'est dans 7 mois
c'est à Paris aux Jeux olympiques mais
bon pour l'instant c'est bien parti
allez le Breton vous êtes à une bonne
nouvelle oui on finit par un petit peu
de foot avec la une du télégram qui
salue le match nul de Brest là encore
arraché 22 contre le PSG au Parc des
Princes les Brestois sont revenus au
score après avoir été mené 2-0 c'est ce
qu'on appelle un bon point bravo la
Bretagne Yve la Une du Figaro c'est les
agriculteurs la tension monte entre les
agriculteurs et l'exécutif exactement on
peut pas dire le
contraire merci merci Mathieu d'avoir
été avec nous merci Alex prochain
rendez-vous à 18h Thomas H sens public
nous on retrouve demain merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi très bonne
journée